okay today I'm going to talk to you
about absolute zero and the Kelvin scale
of temperature so to understand absolute
zero we need to understand how particles
work so when you increase the
temperature of something you give the
particles more energy so they can move
around faster or vibrate more so the
more the higher the temperature the more
their movement so if you decrease the
temperature their movement becomes less
and less and less so as it gets colder
and colder and colder the movement of
these particles decreases and decreases
they have less and less energy now
eventually if you keep on cooling these
particles down eventually they will
essentially have no energy at all or
next to no energy at all and this is
called absolute zero you cannot get any
colder than that it is minus 273 degrees
Celsius so we're talking really really
cold this temperature here that's the
coldest that there can be because you
can't have any less energy than no
energy at all so if the particles have
stopped moving altogether or essentially
stopped moving altogether then we have
this idea of absolute zero so how does
the Kelvin scale of temperature commence
with so Kelvin is just another way
another temperature scale so you could
have degrees Celsius you can have
degrees Fahrenheit you can also have
Kelvin please notice that it isn't
degrees Kelvin it's just k4 Kelvin so
the way that the Kelvin scale starts is
0 K is at Absolute Zero so 0 K is minus
273 degrees C now to help understand
this we're just gonna have a look at
this thermometer here on this side I'm
gonna show Kelvin in fact that you show
you how that's written like that Kelvin
on this side are going to have degrees C
because a change of one Kelvin is the
same as the change of one degree C the
only difference is their starting point
let's have a look at this example so 0 K
is the same as minus 273 degrees C if we
go up by 1k we also go up by 1 degree C
so this time it's minus 270 to 271 3
Kelvin is 270 and so on so as you can
see the difference of 1 Kelvin is the
same as the difference of 1 degrees C
the only difference between the two
scales is their starting point degrees
Celsius starts at 0 degrees C which is
the freezing point of water or the
melting point of water and 0 K is
absolute zero let's just have another
look at another example below here so if
I'd imagine I have 0 sorry zero degrees
C here just up one I'd have 1 degree C
two degrees C this would be minus 1 and
minus 2 so zero degrees C is 273 Kelvin
which means one degree would be 270 for
that would be 275 that would be 270 and
that would be 271 so if you're a little
bit confused about how I got these
numbers from these numbers here's just a
quick way of showing how you convert
from degrees Celsius to Kelvin so if I'm
converting from degrees Celsius to
Kelvin I just need to add 273 and if I'm
converting the other way I just do the
opposite so I just take away 273 I'll
just show a couple of examples
underneath so let's say I wanted to show
25 degrees
in Kelvin so let's have a look at this
up here what I need to do I'm starting
with degrees Celsius so to get to Kelvin
I just need to plus 273 so the answer to
that is 298 K so it's a nice easy
conversion to get from one to the other
let's do it the other way around let's
say I wanted to know what a hundred
Kelvin was in degrees Celsius so for
cause I'm going from Kelvin to degrees
Celsius I need to take away 273 so the
answer this time is minus 173 degrees C
so just to summarize absolute zero is
the point of which particles have so
little energy basically have no energy
at all then do not move the start of
that absolute zero scale is the start of
the Kelvin scale of temperature the
change of one degree is the same as the
change of so one Kelvin is the same as
one degree Celsius and here's a nice
easy way of converting between the two
thank you